so I'm gonna talk to you today so first
let me introduce myself I'm a TANF I had
a product strategy at Apogee at Google
and what I'm going to talk to you today
about is this idea of API first thinking
how you should think about your API is
digital products some of the different
ways that api's gets shared and reused
and how you need to think about api is
as part of an ecosystem rather than just
simply as a way that you are exposing
you know your applications as as as
digital services so one of these and
there's me let me skip past that
generally when we talk about api first
thinking what we're what we mean by that
is this idea that the starting point of
your api's shouldn't simply be what you
have in the database what you have in
your application server or in an
enterprise context what you have in your
enterprise service bus but really
starting from this idea of what are the
experiences that you're trying to power
and what we see in sort of traditional
IT and also I think from sort of a first
order thinking that most developers who
approach this problem come at is to say
you know I have this stack I've this
application that I built I've got you
know perhaps a legacy system that I want
to make available and so api's are just
simply a way that that I expose this
service and depending on how I'm going
about thinking about my API program
perhaps maybe I'm assembling an API team
or maybe this is is more of a informal
micro service concept context and I'm
just sort of you know sharing in an ad
hoc way these are the services I have
available but generally there's this
idea of what at Apogee we would call
this digital value chain which is that
your
exposing these services in a variety of
participants developers go and use these
api's and build applications and they
ultimately may show up powering a set of
applications that that you know a user
actually interacts with and API first
thinking basically reverses that and it
goes and says okay there are a set of
experiences that I need to deliver
there's a set of partnerships that I
want to build you know perhaps I want to
create new types of business models that
that are made possible by api's and I
need to start with that end in mind and
design my api's to meet those needs I
need to think about what the developer
experience is going to be I need to
think about what the Terms of Service
are going to be and I'm going to craft
an API program around that and most
people that we see start from that
previous slide but the really successful
API programs the companies that you see
that are actually based on API so we all
see companies like Twilio and stripe
that have been very successful in
building API based businesses they start
in this way they start thinking about
the developer experience and they start
thinking about as much as possible the
user experiences that these api's may
ultimately power so given that that's
the case why why don't we do this why
doesn't everybody do this well the
answer is there's a lot of different
types of api's in fact they're really
three different ways of viewing api's
and one of the things that I hope you
take away from this presentation is
whenever the API discussion starts up in
in your development teams within your
company in whatever context people start
talking about we should pursue an API
strategy start to have some questions
about what do we mean by these api's
because there's at least three different
forms of api's there's api's really from
a service perspective whether we're
talking about new style micro services
or old style service-oriented
architecture there's AP Isis
interactions and then there's AP Isis
products and we'll look at each one of
these in this presentation and all of
these api's exist within ecosystems that
is the fundamental truth of an API is
that it is designed to share services
share data connect experiences between
systems between applications between
people so you have to think about the
ecosystem consideration regardless of
what the purpose is
which of these three types of API is
that you're building so API is a
services if you're a developer if you're
within IT or whether you're in a
start-up this is the area of api's that
I think most developers sort of
intuitively understand because it's what
we live in what we you know it's it's
how we build our software these days but
these api's take a lot of different
forms even within this context the main
way that most developers end up
interacting with api's is in order to
get to the back-end resources that their
applications need and what we see is
that if you're building an application
you need access to data you need to be
able to interact with the outside world
perhaps via email services most people
are not going in using their
company-wide email server to send out
their email interactions they may be
connecting to an enterprise service bus
or some form of integration architecture
if they're part of an enterprise those
of you in the platforms of service space
if you're using Cloud Foundry of using
Heroku this idea of the 12 factor model
is going to be very familiar to you and
this idea that your application
workloads can scale better if you
separate out the stateful services and
treat them as external services so this
might be a way that you come to start
thinking about api's because this is how
you're going to get it your data or how
you're going to get at your storage or
perhaps even to an external service and
obviously there's a whole set of
companies Google included this is the
nature of the Google cloud platform that
are providing you with a set of
capabilities that are going to be used
to power your applications interestingly
enough in the enterprise space and some
of you are in their press space some of
you in the starb space we see a big
divide in the enterprise space most of
these services that we talk about are
probably sitting behind your firewall
perhaps in your own data center whereas
if you are doing Greenfield new
development if your startup hopefully
you are getting these from the variety
of you know awesome databases of service
or storage service choices that you have
but even if you're doing this internally
you're still thinking this way we see
very few companies that are going and
approaching building new internal
services for their applications where
they're not now thinking about saying
how do we make these restful services
how do we make these API based and in
fact increasingly going and using the
popular developer portal type of format
of allowing internal developers to
discover and use these api's and there's
a lot of interesting work that's being
done here to replace this ESB approach
in in the Cloud Foundry world in the
kubernetes world there's this concept of
a service broker that provides a better
level of mechanism for integrating these
services now inevitably in these
conversations we get questions about
micro services and in fact you know at
Apogee us we interact with customers
this becomes the most common topic these
days which is wait a minute
we're talking about doing micro services
what's the difference between api's and
micro services and also by extension
what's the difference between micro
services service-oriented architecture
so there's a lot of definitions of this
of micro services that float around they
one that I would have really stucked to
when people have asked me what the
difference between micro services so is
is to really talk about the fact that
micro services are trying to
all the scalability problem they're
trying to solve the challenge of
decomposing your application into
independent units of work that can be
scaled at appropriate levels the right
container instances for those workloads
each one can be elastically scaled
independently micro-services generally
are not meant to be a mechanism of reuse
again you know the best analogy to
microservices are we took the components
of the spring world and now we're laying
these out in two containers it lets us
do things like have polyglot programming
within our our development teams these
are all good reasons to use
micro-services it's not to say that you
can't do micro services for the purpose
of sharing and reuse but you need to
understand you are going to pay a
penalty in in terms of agility the wider
you cast a net of your service
dependency graph the more people who
depend on your services the more you
will translate from being or transform
from being a very agile application
development team which may have been the
way you started this journey to being a
service provider who now has to worry
about a whole bunch of other
considerations and it becomes a
full-time job in and of itself these are
the ecosystem considerations I was
referring to previously which I'm going
to get into a little bit more depth
later in this presentation
so the next form of api's and this
really throws a lot of people for a loop
is this idea of api zhis interactions
and in fact as we've worked with
enterprises and most enterprises really
had embraced this idea of
service-oriented or architecture in the
early 2000s and there were a set of
blueprints and patterns for reuse that
designing services the level of service
granularity and so forth really were
encouraged as best practices those
proved to be anti-patterns when you went
to move towards mobile and they actually
further hampered a lot of people as they
tried to embrace things like IOT
we're a number of reasons for this but
the idea was that these services that
you use to power front-end interactions
look very different than services that
you use to expose back-end resources
they are purpose-built these experience
api's that determine the Netflix coined
to describe these and it's it's caught
on for people who sort of study
different API design patterns look very
different then the services that are
designed for wide reuse that perhaps
you're using when you're building a
back-end service that you want to be
used by many different applications and
in fact the lifespan of these is very
different in the mobile world you
further compound this with the fact that
many mobile developers if there's no SDK
to access these api's consider the API
in completing and so that's why when you
see companies that are trying to succeed
with mobile developers if you look at
for example firebase provides a real
first-class mobile experience they do so
by providing very well-built ap SDKs
that developers can easily integrate
into whatever idea IDE environment that
they're using Xcode what have you
they've put a lot of thought into this
developer experience most API developers
most API architects that I talk to they
sort of want to push as much as possible
this you know this SDK problem off to
the side you do see some good approaches
a lot of the popularity of swagger now
open API has come about because it
allows you to express these api's in a
way that can quickly be accessed via
SDKs client libraries that can be
auto-generated from the api's now
experience API is add a new wrinkle in
that some of these again are
purpose-built they are not designed for
reuse they may be built by your
front-end developers so you may have one
team that's building your API is for
general reuse but you've got your web
developers who are building single page
apps who need special api's to power
those experiences and you may have these
Afra mention mobile clients that again
need specific api's to power specific
experiences you know anybody who goes to
a shopping site you go to Amazon you see
a Buy It Now button obviously downstream
you are going to go and have an inner
API that handles the payment processing
but there's going to be a separate
interaction or experience API that's
powering that Buy It Now button this is
not an anti-pattern you can have you can
have multiple forms of api's to power
multiple forms of interactions the way
you do that is by having this mediation
layer and so companies that are building
user experiences around api's have some
form of mediation layer that might be
something that was built in no js' in
fact a lot of the popularity for node
has come from the fact that because it's
JavaScript because you know JSON is the
native data format it's a great place to
go and basically create this this
mediation tier that can go and take this
back-end inner API that might have been
designed for general purpose use and
create these small services that are
purpose-built for perhaps a specific
interaction when user hits a button on
your mobile app the role of API
management platforms if you want to know
why do a lot of companies deploy
technologies like Apogee API management
platforms provide this mediation layer
type mechanism and so so this might be a
reason why you find yourself looking at
that sort of product or technology so
the third aspect of API is is API zhis
products and this tends to really
separate out the thinking from those two
previous instances in the scenarios
where you're thinking about API is a
services it's really your developers
your your software development team
leads that perhaps are thinking about
what services are being designed for
wider reuse in in AP has its
interactions it's probably a front-end
team but now you've got the scenario
where you go and say I want to build a
business model around api's and in that
case
what you're doing is you're really
thinking about how you are going to
manage these API zhis products and this
tends to trip people up because there's
a number of different folks involved in
building API so you've got your
developers that build the API you have a
set of people who are testing them you
have a whole set of operational concerns
whether you're doing sort of classic
Enterprise style centralized ops or
whether you're using more of a DevOps
focus you still have a whole set of
considerations around that now you've
got to think about how you manage this
API lifecycle and what we've seen is is
the companies are successful with this
have somebody in the role of API product
manager and it's not always a full-time
job it might be part of another role but
there is somebody whose job it is to
make sure that all aspects of the API
lifecycle and most importantly the
critical metrics that determine whether
the API is succeeding are being looked
after so when you're productizing an API
suddenly you now have considerations and
if you're this API product manager
you're very focused on your API design
if you're building a payment processing
API we've got a number of customers that
are you know offering payment
transaction gateways if you're the
product manager of one of those API so
you're going and saying how can I
provide a better developer experience
than someone like stripe you know and
the way you're doing that is through
superior documentation perhaps better
client SDKs and you're looking at the
design of the API itself do you know is
is the amount of parameters I have to
send are these payloads are they the
right size are they easy for developers
to wrap their heads around or do after
consider and send a lot of data that
really doesn't make sense for my
application that's where API design
comes in is it properly designed from
restful best practices a lot of new
security concerns one of the things that
we've seen as we've been in a lot of
these API hackathons is that the
challenged people have developers in
using a new API is getting the
authentication right it's a big problem
simply just going and saying it's OAuth
isn't always the solution there's still
a lot of things that that need to be
improved in getting developers to be
able to understand and be able to go and
make a curl call that allows them to
actually get results from an API and
then the last piece and this is probably
the biggest set of considerations that
the would-be API product manager needs
to to think about is the metrics for
success this is the difference between
API cz's of product or just api's as a
project your metrics for success from an
API are going to be different depending
on your business John Mercer the founder
of programmable web several years ago
made the observation that I agree with
that
you need to regardless of the context of
what your API is are for you need to go
and think about the classic marketing
funnel some of you who are going and say
hey I'm building API this mean I'm a
marketing person well not necessarily
but you have to think about how people
are going to be adopting these and every
step that they're going through and so
he identified a set of metrics and a
process that goes along with those
metrics from finding developers perhaps
promoting your API it gets picked up on
Hacker News it gets found via Google
searches people are tweeting about it
what have you you're getting them to go
to a developer portal they're signing up
for it they're using it within an
application you've got active usage of
that API within a number of apps that
they shipped perhaps you've got
monetization associated with it this is
going to be different for you
everybody's API business is different
some of this won't apply because you're
doing internal api's but even in
internal API ecosystems there will be a
set of metrics that you need to manage -
this is what it means to be a service
provider because you need to know your
customers and in order to provide
quality of service you need to be
basically managing - these metrics so
hopefully these three forms of api's
makes sense hopefully for those of you
who are involved in api projects you're
able to think about and map what you're
doing to these types of api's but what I
want to talk about now is the ecosystem
that the API sit within because this is
where things really get interesting it's
not as simple as just going and saying
you know am i exposing my API us rest or
I see this G RPC thing what are the
technical considerations do I you know
use a gateway with caching or not all of
those requirements are very important
but it's the ecosystems that you're
api's are used at used by that really is
the whole reason why you're doing this
most businesses do operate within
ecosystems if you are a company that is
becoming a digital business you probably
are already moving many of your supply
chains your value chains to be digitally
mediated and that might be what's
driving your your API thinking you may
internally within your IT processes
those represent a ecosystem and a value
chain most of what we're talking about
here is what the people who get all
excited about this stuff tends to be
industry analysts tends not so much to
be developers and IT people start
talking about you know what your value
chains are well hopefully it's a service
a prime primer to that you generally
when you're building api's you're going
to be serving one or more ecosystems
you're going to have your internal
ecosystems those are sort of the api's
you share with your friends on your team
your your internal developers but this
range is out there might be partner
ecosystems there might be industry
ecosystems there might be public
ecosystems these all have new
considerations new requirements
generally what we see is people sort of
take this approach that I'm sorry to say
is a little naive but that said it's the
path everyone takes which is to go and
say well we're gonna build our API for
internal usage and and then we're gonna
going to open them up to the outside
world and it'll be great
tends to you tend to find going back to
my first slide that a whole bunch of new
considerations hit you over the head
hopefully halfway through this
presentation you're starting to get an
inkling of what some of those are but
let's talk about how these these
ecosystems are different if you're doing
ecosystems for your API services they're
predominantly internal these are what
you're doing to share and reuse your
your the applications you build the
systems you build the back-end resources
you build with other developers there's
a number of different approaches to this
there's the classic so approach now
people who were so architects so often
so stands for service-oriented
architecture
those of us who were around at the time
go and say well you know there's nothing
wrong with so it just simply says we
should build a services that should be
designed for reuse and you'll get all
sorts of productivity gains from that
what we found was that most
organizations ended up finding that you
ended up having to impose a strong form
of central governance in order to make
this happen and there's a slippery slope
that gets you there and I actually
believe that about half the companies
that are embracing micro services are
going to end up there the way that you
end up on this slippery slope is just
going and saying all we have to do is
agree to a common set of conventions and
all of our services can be reused then
nobody can agree what those common set
of conventions are hence the strong
central governance model now what tends
to work is this idea of an API
management model an API model where you
go and say look I am going to expose
this API in this way it will be a
restful api so all of your clients can
talk to it we are going to document it
in standard ways we're going to use the
open API specification to document it
and I'm going to stand up a developer
portal and that's where you're gonna
find it and if that API doesn't work the
way you like then what you should do is
you know build your own client libraries
to access it and perhaps use your own
you
Middleware if you will perhaps use
nodejs if it's something you want to
build yourself to shape and convert that
api to your use cases this tends to work
very well we see that the interaction
model and tent and that nodejs as I said
before that nodejs model tends to be
most closely associated with situations
where these api's need to be exposed for
interaction purposes this has a lot of
interesting aspects to it you know
mobile was the main driver for this but
we now see things like conversational
computing we see things like if you're
using Google assistant if you're using
Alexa if using any of these seria you're
seeing that that you now have the
ability if you actually are delivering
your services within standard
interaction models that they can be now
used within these new types of
conversational interaction models but we
also see that there's a lot of business
drivers for this retail people look at
this and folks in the retail industry
they go and say this is how I'm going to
power on the channel interaction models
and you find that there's this need to
go and make your api's available in in
standard ways so that you can actually
talk to an e-commerce stack you might be
able to talk to some form of direct
response email interaction system and so
on these tend to try supporting an
ecosystem in this model tends to try or
Drive you to getting your API is to fit
certain patterns right now I say
patterns not standards aren't as many
standards in this areas there could be
and you know I think that that both of
these models people tend not to think of
themselves as a participating ecosystem
but I think increasingly you're going to
let me talk about the product ecosystems
because I think those are where things
get the most interesting so within the
product ecosystems there's a variety of
different ways that people make their
api's available
for use by by by other folks so
basically the idea here is that you're
taking your business capability you're
packaging it up as a building block that
other companies can go and embed in
their business processes so in terms of
how you find these api's right now the
predominant way that people find and
interact with api's is really sort of
this one-sided traditional commerce
model where people go and discover the
API usually through a pre-existing
business relationship or they are
leveraging one of the sort of major
brands if I'm going and I need to send
an SMS API the API there's there's a set
of choices very well known choices
people learn about these through
conventional marketing mechanisms but
where things get more interesting is
where you have this platform oriented
approach where you actually can bring
these api's together and promote them
and combine them in different ways some
of the examples of this that we see are
for example if you look at the
partnership between mind body which is
provides scheduling services for for
things like yoga studios fitness centers
and so on and what's happened with
Google Maps this is an example of where
you actually see a two-sided
relationship where both companies are
actually sharing services and data
between each other to create two
different application experiences with a
whole bunch of synergy between them so
if I go to Google Maps and I go and I
say I want to be able to go and and you
know book a session with a fitness
instructor I can go in and do that and
Google Maps will call out to the
mind-body API and they'll be able to
find the nearest fitness center where
that's available and directly book it
that's what we actually see in the right
hand side with this screen that's
showing reserved with Google I can get
to this via the map
user experience now the flip side of
this is that you've got Google Maps
itself integrating with with mind body
within its application so if my body is
providing a private-label application to
a specific chain of fitness centers or
to end-users through the variety of
channels that they do that that that
users are able to go and get access to
google maps with all of its location
location-based services but in the
context of this application experience
so I think that what we're seeing very
successful within the API space is where
you're able to basically cross pollinate
this experience by sharing data and
process some of the other forms of this
slide are things that I think you're
going to see more of as we look out in
the future of different forms of
ecosystems one of the things I wanted to
leave you with at the end of this
presentation is this print this session
that I just did is the first part of
what we're calling the connected
business track here at at Google next
tomorrow Chet Kapoor CEO of apogee at
Google is going to be talking about this
vision of a connected business platform
and how all of these different
ecosystems power different types of
business models and some of these
business models that we see are actually
these clearinghouses and marketplaces
for digital services and we'll get into
a lot more depth in that keynote
tomorrow so let me wrap this up so when
we talk about API first and we talked
about API centric thinking hopefully
this presentation has given you kind of
this perspective of thinking about this
outside in approach even if you're api's
are predominantly being used for
internal purposes it makes sense if your
scope of reuse is wide enough if you are
working with other development teams
that are sort of beyond arm's length
where you're not scrubbing with them or
you're not regularly interacting with
them once
you need to suddenly be thinking about
your API consumers as customers now if
your API is are designed for for being
API zhis products and you definitely are
gonna have to think about this the
competitiveness of your API the success
of your API as a product really will
come down to the developer experience
that you create and the quality of
service that you provide being able to
identify what form of API that you're
building is it simply designed for
service reuses and a micro service is it
something that's powering an interaction
or is it this API sub product is going
to help you think about how you organize
your team around it where it sits within
your organization if it is designed for
API as a service in that in that
classical sense maybe it is something
that sits if you're in an IT
organization that sits within you know
your your classic integration center of
excellence although we are CP generally
we see and advocate people move away
from that strong centralized model if
it's an interaction it's probably
sitting with your front-end team but
even if it is you now have
considerations like how do I allow my
front-end team to go and build these
interaction api's and make sure they're
still secure and if their API is a
product then do you have an api product
manager this last concept of managing
your api is the digital partnership
super-important this tends to be the
lightbulb moment for most folks when
they think about their their api
programs particularly when you're
bridging into trying to explain the
value of api's to the business folks in
your organization's suddenly when people
understand an api is a digital
partnership they understand all the
responsibilities and opportunities that
go along with that
and finally regardless of how you're
using api's you have to think about the
ecosystems the nature of the ecosystems
will be different for each one of those
api's but ultimately the moment you've
got one other person beyond the person
who built their API built that API using
API you now have an ecosystem that you
need to cultivate
and grow and make successful